can you do a tarot card reading for me
oh my God I wish I brought them yeah
what is what are you just walking around
set looking to do reading every day no
no they come to me oh interesting they
come to
me so we're talking about Golden Globes
this week and one of the films that was
up for awards was wicked and we already
did a peace on Wicked talking about some
of the elements shall we say that are in
there you can find that link in the
description below um but you know so far
everybody that's watched me put this up
has asked about this image so far with
Cynthia Revo and they're like didn't
quite notice that her hands are in her
pocket so like what's with the hands on
her shoulders it's like kind of scary
looking you know it's like demon hands
or something yeah it looks like AI
generated yeah it does kind of look AI
generated but I think it's just part of
the outfit she wore some demon hands on
her shoulders
but you know the whole movie and
Disney's emo for a long time has has
been witchcraft I mean they they have it
in everything from way far back so this
is no different you know the wizard of O
story there's witches in there the witch
Good Witch of the West the W the Good
Witch of the North all that kind of
stuff it's witches right so anyway it
was up for some Golden Globe awards it
was up for cinematic and box office
achievement it was up for best
supporting actress for motion picture it
was up for best actress for em Motion
Picture specifically a musical or comedy
and it was up for best motion Motion
Picture musical or comedy and it
actually won for cinematic and box
office achievement so a lot of people
went to watch it then yeah a lot of
people went to watch it but it only won
the one award it and Scotty just
beforehand was saying that it it won for
most wicked movie which had us all
laughing I'm I'm disturbed that this is
what we're honoring you know what I mean
it's like we're so like heralding this
this this if this is not a barometer for
where we are in life right now this is
just like yeah it's awful yeah we
celebrate wickedness you know there were
some somebody sent this to us so um a
lot of times people that are watching
and you guys send us stuff doesn't
always mean that it's going to make it
in a show but occasionally there' be
like little tidbits we can glean so
somebody was watching I forget the name
sent this um to us and I found a clip
that that at least discusses what it was
about I couldn't find the clip at self I
think it was like a temporary Instagram
post so it like goes up and then goes
down um but I want to show you guys
something that John Chu had said about
his child being born you wouldn't think
that was news noteworthy with Wicked but
during this production he had three kids
that's how long he worked on it John Chu
is the director the director yeah so
watch what he said about um this film
relas watch this
clip John mchu is sharing the first
adorable clip of his new baby girl on
Saturday November 9th the wicked
director 45 posted a video on his
Instagram stories of his baby daughter
and fifth child in the hospital shortly
after she was born her arrival came the
same day as the Los Angeles premiere of
the hotly anticipated movie which stars
Ariana Grande and cythia rivo I can't
believe this happened while the movie is
premiering Chu wrote in a message over
the video magic is in the air happy
Premier day Welcome to our world you're
going to do great you have a lot of
witches on your side greenhart he
concluded lot of witches on your side
excuse me so basically he's calling his
baby a witch yeah well he ain't a lot of
witches on your side like probably
Cynthia and Ariana cuz they're in the
movie they're playing witches we're
hoping we're
hoping yeah that's that's what he's
talking about but you know it might
actually go further than that not not by
something we're just making up but by
like their own admission right you think
okay they're just playing witches for
the movie but maybe there's more to that
maybe this is like a real life thing can
you imagine may like yeah yeah you're a
wicked director I mean just a weird
title to begin with it is but like
honestly I I think these people are real
real world witches actually do yeah so
here's a clip uh done in an interview
with Ariana Grande talking about that
very thing but there has is there an in
between anywhere where like CRA meets
the universe yeah yeah yeah I'm
somewhere in between I've learned I
don't know I sit somewhere between being
a literal witch literal witch I'm not
kidding and being like the most
realistic cut dry
like you know yeah totally I don't know
I feel like I'm my most productive when
I am open and uh also when I pretend no
one's ever going to hear it that's when
I'm my my my best I think at what point
in the process do you have to be
reminded that people will hear it when
it's over got it and then I backtrack
many steps and I clean things up and I
figure it out just kidding Supernatural
mhm and so she's admitting that she's a
witch I mean we didn't say it right she
said it she said a literal witch said
itce she emphasized it like and I'm not
kidding yeah yeah yeah I mean
interesting I mean it would make sense
you would think of actors when they
receive a role they have to study the
role almost some some people going into
a method acting becoming the
character uh now I wonder if they chose
her because she was already a witch or
if she became a witch because she had to
be a witch in the movie no it just seems
fitting no she came from Disney right so
I'm just going to go out a limb here I
think Disney's like literally
like priming people priming people with
this witchcraft stuff but not only that
I think there's a lot of people involved
in witchcraft that are actually working
for Disney I mean I really that makes
sense I I I I think this is what they're
interested in um which is why you see
all that symbolism worked in and but you
just think I mean it's it's it's it's
everywhere I mean you think Mickey Mouse
way back right and uh what was the
Fantasia Sorcerer Apprentice yeah the
sorcerer apprentice there's this big
black winged demon looking thing in
there and it's like what that's for
little kids that was their poster yeah
all about magic yeah it's all about like
this witchcraft it's for little kids and
it's like going to give kids nightmares
so at this point you think okay well she
said maybe she's like well I'm I'm just
you know I'm kind of halfway somewhere
in between but I'm a witch I'm a literal
a witch and you're thinking okay if that
isn't enough later in the same interview
listen to what she says can you do a
tarot card reading for me oh my God I
wish I brought them yeah what is what
are you just walking around set looking
to do reading every day no no they come
to me oh interesting they come to me you
are a witch I am indeed the witchiest
witch something happened recently that I
actually couldn't wrap my head around I
need to remember it I need to remember
it to be fair you couldn't wrap your
head around it so it was the witchiest
thing yeah I couldn't and I didn't I
forgot it clear keep going there's
something really witchy oh Jim carries
birthday thank you Mom I announced
Eternal Sunshine on Jim's birthday and I
didn't know it was his
birthday so Jim car's a
witch think she's at that know I'm just
kidding but apparently she announced
something about that without yeah I
guess without knowing it by doing a
tarot card reading s witchiest thing
ever I mean the fact that she says
literally she's bringing this on to set
and people on the set are are cominging
to her you know there's a lot of movies
that put tarot cards in the movies I
first saw that with Batman Batman you
know and when when when in the dark
night when they threw the Joker off the
roof um the writer said that was the
hanged man and then in the very next
movie that uh he ler played in they
showed the hanged man yep and I even
found in the penguin they talked about
the hanged man and it was like those are
all tarot cards so this is a this is a
real world thing that I think that
they're not only doing on set but
they're working into the material but
just openly casually just like admitting
it like no big deal like this just goes
on it just happens yeah so very strange
but yeah you wonder like were they
chosen
because they already knew I mean
Hollywood is kind of a small town I
think if you're like in the circles and
the no it's probably not that big mhm
you would know better than than we would
but people that are actually successful
I'm sure they're all part of the same
yeah small group yeah same small group
so where I want to land with all this is
is this and there are many other verses
we could go maybe you guys will bring up
a couple but when we get to the end of
the book right the story is wrapping up
right in the Bible story is wrapping up
where we're being told how everything's
going to end here's what it says in
Revelation 213 and I heard a loud voice
from Heaven saying behold the Tabernacle
of God is with men and he will dwell
with them they shall be his people and
God himself will be with them and be
their God and God will wipe away every
tear from their eyes there shall be no
more death no more sorrow no more crying
no more pain but the former things are
passed away so God is is essentially
laying out none of this is going to
happen anymore it's great older I get
the more I appreciate this right more
pain you have the more pain you have the
more suffering you know the more death
the people in your life you know that
all goes away what's fascinating is to
me is like this is listed first and
we're and and we're being told God is
going to be with us that restoration
that was removed from Eden right God was
separated from man sin the Bible says
separates us from God so by implication
no more sin it goes on it says then he
who sat on the throne said behold I make
all things new and he said to me write
for these words are true and faithful
and he said to me it is done I'm the
alpha the Omega the beginning the end I
will give of the Fountain of Water of
Life freely to him who thirsts he who
overcomes shall inherit all things and I
will be his God and he shall be my
son okay
overcome all
things like what when you're reading the
narrative often times the Bible is
telling you what it's talking about
before it's going to talk about it so we
get to verse
8 but the Cowardly the unbelieving the
abominable murderers sexual immoral
Sorcerers idolators and all liars shall
have their part in the lake which burns
with fire and brimstone which is the
second death all these things are part
of that overcoming process that God is
talking about because these aren't part
of the picture in the end these aren't
part of the story the story is done God
says these are all gone they're they're
no more these aren't a part of my
kingdom this goes away so why would we
want to have anything to do with any of
that witchcraft in general takes the
power away from God yeah it's it's a
counterfeit Miracle because something
Supernatural is happening and I think
that's why Hollywood's really attracted
to it because it's like leaving God out
of the equation I can make this
Supernatural thing happen or I can make
this like crazy hard thing you can be
like God I can be the one that controls
the
situation and um but you know like magic
and sorcery they are literally saying if
I say the right words or I mix the right
potion or I do the right things then I
can make that outcome happen and I think
that's what you're seeing here is like
you know Witchcraft and all that oh
they're really not bad you know we've
just described evil to them that was the
thing with with Wicked was in the
beginning um trailer to this that was
the one thing yeah is evil uh just
thrust onto people or is it literally
just are they born with it are you evil
yeah so what does that do that really
takes the application of well I'm not
really evil it's just somebody thrust
this on me so who thrusted on me if God
says these things right here are evil
whose fault is it yeah by implication
it's God's fault no it's God's fault and
God's saying these things will not exist
in the new Heavens yeah so I don't know
probably a lot of people get the
impression that well we're just down on
all these people and all this but we
pray about it we pray for these people
we pray that they would come away from
this kind of stuff that they're going to
learn and occasionally denque I know has
like been pretty bold and sent People
literature you know at least tried to
draw them away from these kinds of
things so um you know our invitation to
you the viewer pray for these people as
well they're caught up in some really
terrible stuff that's going to affect
their Eternal salvation we don't want
that for them and we don't want it for
us and so Christians you know don't have
anything to do with these kind of things
it's not going to be a part of God's
kingdom in the end but by implication
shouldn't be a about part of God's
kingdom now or people that are part of
God's Kingdom so well this is uh been a
week of Golden Globe commentary so we
hope you enjoy this we're trying to put
more of these out uh if you want to
check out our merch we have lightwear
you can go to lightwear do shop check
out our merch I think we're all wearing
some of that today so great check that
out and also if you want to help support
this work make sure you go to little
light studios. tv/ donate or LLS .tv
/give and uh you can help us out that
way but thank you for watching thank you
for joining us and being part of the
conversation and we'll see you next time
thanks it's proven that people remember
things that they see more than what they
hear lightwear believes the best way to
share your witness is to wear your
witness lightwear has all kinds of
graphic te's that are a great attention
grabbing way to share the gospel so head
on over to lightwear do shop and check
out all the cool graphic te's what do
you want people to remember when they
see you
[Music]
hey subscribe to little
Studios if you want to learn Spanish a
great way will'll be watching our videos
for practice
[Music]
oh